u
de cette joute politique.
- Ils ont cru à une route
sans trop d'entraves vers
l'Europe. Depuis la Syrie,
la Jordanie ou le Kurdistan,
un visa et billet d'avion
pour Minsk en poche.
Direction : les portes
ope, à la frontière
de la Pologne. Mais ce sont
les échecs répétés qui
les attendaient. Des échecs
marqués par la faim, la soif,
le froid, la peur et les chiens.
- "On est entrés dans la forêt
et ils ont lancé les chiens
sur nous parce qu'ils
ne pouvaient pas entrer
dans la forêt," raconte Raad.
"Ils ont envoyé les chiens
pour nous poursuivre,
et le mal est arrivé."
Mordu et blessé à la tête
et au bras par le chien
de la police polonaise,
Raad a dû être hospitalisé
une vingtaine de jours.
Autour d'un repas expéditif,
tous ces hommes ne pensent
qu'à leur prochaine étape.
La Pologne n'a jamais été
qu'un posage sur
la route de l'ouest de l'Europe.
"Il y a des passeurs
qui peuvent aider", dit Raad.
"Il déteste la Pologne et
ses policiers. Les Biélorusses,
eux, ont été formidables",
dit-il.
"Ils sont très bons, très,
très boffrent
la protection, ils te coupent
les barbelés de la clôture
et ils te disent : par là,
c'est sûr; par là, c'est risqué.
ime beaucoup."
C'est bien ce que les Européens
reprochent à la Biélorussie.
Ils accusent son président
Alexandre Loukachenko
d'avoir orchestré cette vaguemir
de sanctions européennes.
Dans cette nouvelle joute
d'échec entre la Biélorussie
et l'Union européenne qui
se joue sur l'espoir trompé
de ces hommes, femmes et
enfants, la Pologne n'est pas
le problle ministre
des Affaires étrangères
de l'Allemagne. Il est temps
pour l'Europe de tirer
les conséquences de cette
nouvelle crise et d'agir.
"L'Union européenne va
étendre et renforcer
tions contre le régime
de Loukachenko", a-t-il dit.
Le président de la Biélorussie
se fait tout aussi menaçant.
Si l'Europe riposte par
de nouvelles sanctions,
il coupera le gaz
transite par son pays.
"S'ils nous imposent de
nouvelles sanctions indigestes
et inacceptables pour nous,
nous devons répondre",
a-t-il dit.
La Pologne a décrété l'état
d'urgence sur tout
près de la frontière,
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a
un vide humanitaire qui se crée.
Interdiction d'entrée pour
les organisations qui cherchent
à venir en aide aux gens,
qui sont en forêt. Interdiction
d'entrer aussi pour
les jour on ne peut
pas voir directement
ce qu'il se passe à
la frontière.
Ce sont 183 localités qui
sont ainsi retranchées
derrières des cordons policiers.
15 000 soldats polonais sont
déployés à la frontière
pour empêcher les migrants
de passer. Un blocage qui
n'est pas complètement étanche.
Entre 400 et 750 tentatives
de traversée se font tous
les jours, selon les autorit
polonaises. Mais il y a aussi
ceux qui arrivent à franchir
la frontière pour se retrouver
dans les bois du côté polonais.
Teseross jeunes
enfants et son mari sont restés
cinq jours à marcher dans
le froid de la forêt polonaise
avant d'être arrêtés. La jeune
femme, enceinte de six mois,
a dû être hospitalisée
quand on l'a retrouvée.
Mina, sa fille de 8 ans,
raconte le terrifiant jeu
du chat et de la souris
pour éviter les policiers.
"Quand les voitures de police
passaient près de nous,
nous ne pouvions que tenter
de nous cacher. On a essayé
de franchide franchide franchide
de la frontière, mais pour ma
mère, c'était très difficile."
"Les enfants jouent encore
à se cacher de la police,"
raconte Teseros, qui espère
que ça ne devienne
qu'un lointain souvenir."
"Tout le monde fait face à
de bons et mauvais moments",
dit-elle. "Mais ap
le mauvais, il y aura
le bon. Enfin, c'est c'est
ce que j'espère."
Ils pourront maintenant rester
dans ce centre géré par
une organisation humanitairelqu?
Tous ici ont exprimé le désir
de poursuivre leur chemin,
vers un ailleurs indéfini,
là où il fait bon vivre
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada,